okay let's go back to the phones at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 we've got a lot of people
holding today let's see where we want to
go next why don't we talk to a lot of
area codes I don't recognize let's go to
our caller from the six four seven area
code who's calling today from six four
seven hi David it's Eric from Toronto
hey Eric what's going on today yeah I
wondered if if you know much about
citizens assemblies I've been reading a
lot about the topic lately and I wonder
what you thought about them as a
problem-solving mechanism no I've not
heard of them by that name but what are
they because I think it sounds like it's
something I know by a different name
okay a citizen's assembly is an assembly
of randomly selected citizens convened
to consider a problem listen to experts
and deliberate with help from some
moderators and propose solution it's
kind of like legislation by jury yeah
exactly I was going to make the analogy
to the jury I mean listen I love the
idea in principle and one of the biggest
problems we have I don't know how big of
a problem it is in Canada but in the
u.s. one of the biggest problems we have
within the sort of a sphere of elected
officials is that they are coming
disproportionately from narrow slices of
society in terms of their professions in
terms of their financial circumstances
and in other ways it's a relatively
homogeneous group that lacks diversity
in ways that I think would be important
I'm not talking about racial diversity
but in these other ways the problem is
like I've been on a jury and it's pretty
bad and I did a segment which now I
think has more than half a million views
on YouTube saying we have to recognize
that there's just a lot of people that
are ignorant dumb stupid call it
whatever you want I don't want to
stigmatize it but there's just a lot of
people that lack information and
cognitive ability so I want more
diversity of voices in deciding how our
society should be organized and and
weighing in on policy at the same time
I've been on a jury where two-thirds of
the jury members didn't even understand
what the law was that we were supposed
to make a guilty or not guilty
determination of so it also scares me
and I understand like when you go back
you know to Plato and see his
anti-democracy views I understand them
I'm not I'm not an anti I'm not against
democracy but I understand the problem
with just letting random people be in
charge of stuff I've been on juries you
know well I think that's a very good
point although you know it has been
tried in a couple of areas of the world
such as British Columbia had one about
electoral reform Ireland had one about
abortions and I think really the results
speak for themselves there if you can
get experts in front of these people if
you can have moderators you know getting
them to discuss in a productive way
people really do change their minds and
come to what I think are reasonable
solutions to complicated problems that's
fantastic I mean it's it's heartwarming
and inspirational that there are
examples of it having worked well and I
would be super in favor of the idea as
long as I felt good about you know not
listen 60 million people voted for Trump
it's like how how how critically are you
thinking if you go to the ballot box and
say I want Donald Trump to be President
and that's what's really scary to me
mm-hmm
yeah one of the things it seems like
citizens assemblies can really change if
they took over a lot more of the
legislative role from elected
representatives is that the role of
political parties in society could be
marginalized a lot and that might get
rid of a lot of the toxic culture around
politics that is troubling many areas of
the world today completely agree
although I think that there's also the
possibility that in so doing it allows
for other new problems that we would
have to solve but super interesting and
I'll look into it further I appreciate
you bringing it up all right have a
great day okay you too appreciate the
call